feel good hello everyone and welcome to
today's podcast we are the fields good
podcast i am jaclyn fernandez
and i am amanda cerny
but moving on amanda we have an amazing
guest with us today that you are sure to
know and
love having starred in favorites such as
school of rock nickelodeon sitcom
sitcom i carly drake and josh which i
used to watch
literally like every day of my life
margot
in despicable me and in 2020 hosting
mission unstoppable with miranda
cosgrove she is also no stranger to the
music world releasing icarly about you
sparks fly high maintenance and dancing
crazy please welcome
my dear friend miranda cosgrove miranda
it was a really nice intro thing
yeah i mean it was a humble one you've
done so much you're so freaking awesome
you're so smart i've watched some of
those episodes
of mission unstoppable so i have a lot
to learn from you
blowing my mind so that's where you do
like um
science just learning everything you're
like a bill nye
but like even cooler than a bill now am
i the science guy
because honestly i know nothing about
science at all
so getting to do it it's like it's fun
getting to learn new stuff like maybe
that's how you guys feel when you're
doing the podcast
it really is because everybody we talk
to
teaches us something we learn so much
like just hearing
somebody's story you learn so much of
just
what their process is and even from
their story you just learn
life lessons with every single person's
story it's so
true and ryan it's like we're so
inspired by you as well
like you start at what age again um i
started acting when i was three and like
a really weird i mean i didn't really
act
when i was three i was i was at like um
like a
food festival with my mom and an agent
like came up to my mom because i'm from
l.a
so it's just really random and i ended
up going on some auditions i think i was
in like a kmart ad
and a burger king commercial and stuff
like that
and then i just kept doing it um like
going on auditions
like randomly when i was little and
ended up um acting or ended up getting
parts and acting it's kind of weird
[Laughter]
so humble but i think um when you're
three
did you realize like did you see the ads
and were you excited or did you see the
ads and you were like
huh where's my toys
um i don't really remember being that
little but i remember um
when i was like eight and i was on the
show drake and joshua nickelodeon like i
remember
going to school because i went to public
school and
um like nobody i like two friends and
like nobody
cared about me at all and then when that
came out like
all of a sudden all these kids at school
were like excited about it and really
coming up to me at recess
and stuff and i remember that happening
and you're like
wow did you accept them as friends or
were you just like
no i think i was like really excited
about it
yeah like what does that do to you as a
kid like
i mean like when all of a sudden you
just become super popular and like you
know
like everyone kind of like wants to like
be your friend like what does that do to
you
like i know like you were super excited
but like after some time did you come to
understand
like did it make you think about things
differently um
maybe a little bit i mean i remember
there was this kid in elementary
school named curtis phillips who i was
madly in love with
and he didn't really know i existed and
then he ended up liking drake and josh
and he asked me to go to the movies
oh he was really big in fifth grade um
but then there was a whole drama because
he actually liked another girl
more and he only liked me because of the
show
so it's all it was all like elementary
school drama
so you wanted the best of both worlds
you wanted
the clout and the you know he missed out
that guy missed out curtis if you're
watching this now
no miranda will not date you she will
not take you back
one chance for him recently did you know
miranda
i'm like looking at past options it's
gotten to that point
because of coven
[Music]
speaking of because you definitely can't
go out i mean it's not
a laughing matter miranda actually has
coven
and um but you're feeling okay you've
had
headaches or like what were you like
your symptoms how did you know to go get
tested yeah
um i actually i've i tested because i
worked one day
and then i tested negative and then i
actually wasn't feeling that bad but
maybe
a week after i tested negative i tested
again it wasn't really because i wasn't
feeling well as
much as i just kind of test once every
couple weeks or once a week to make sure
because my parents are older
um but i was really surprised when it
came out positive
i had a headache a little bit the day i
got the results
and um i don't really get headaches a
lot and it was
it hurt it was a pretty bad one so um
i thought that was kind of strange but
for some reason cobit didn't cross my
mind i'm not sure why
um maybe i was in denial a little bit
but then when it came up and said
positive i was really surprised and then
i just had the headache for a few days
and i lost my taste and smell um and i
still don't have my taste
or smell back but other than that i
really don't have any symptoms
um crazy and for thanksgiving too you
couldn't eat anything
what did you have for thanksgiving um i
actually
have it's weird i've been eating more
you think that i'd eat less
because you can't really taste anything
but i've been eating more because
um i keep thinking if i keep trying
different things eventually something
will
taste like itself again so i just keep
drying all this stuff
and so far it's kind of strange because
it's like salt you can actually taste
salty things a little bit
i don't know if everyone's like that but
you can taste really basic steps
oh my god i can't believe you actually
like lose your
like they say like that's the first
thing like if you feel if you haven't
been tested but like all of a sudden
you've lost your taste and your smell
that means you have it and i can't like
so so what are you actually are you on
any medication or something right now
no i got really lucky or i've been
really lucky so far because i haven't
had
a cough or any breathing problems i've
only had
the sort of a migraine and not anymore
and just the taste and smell but it is
really strange because
you know if i'm doing laundry or
literally anything i can't smell
anything
it's just strange to not be able to but
i'm really lucky compared to
a lot of people obviously yeah yeah
when people get it really bad when
people text you to hang out
um or to like do stuff
do you just say hey i have covid and
what's their reaction
are they more concerned about
who's heard about it but like when i
first got it
i was kind of i'm not even gonna lie i
was kind of embarrassed to tell people
because you have to contact anyone
you've been around i think it was within
like a week before you
get the the positive result so just
contacting people was horrible because
obviously everyone's panicking and
nobody wants to get it
and then having to just text people and
be like i'm positive
is not the most fun experience
but um i also got really lucky because
nobody i've texted
ended up testing positive two so i
wasn't able to figure out exactly
how i got it um so it sort of
kind of i hurt my ankle i i'm really
klutzy and i sprained
my ankle and i went to do an x-ray so i
was thinking
it's possible maybe i got it when i went
to do the x-ray at the doctor's office
but everyone was wearing masks and stuff
so i don't know but they say actually
the hospital is one of the most common
places to get it
like going there and yeah and even just
people getting tested over there
it's like even if you're negative you
could turn out positive so it almost
is like not even a good idea to be at
any kind of hospital right now
oh no that's terrible but i guess also
because you're working like we're all
working we're out and about
um we have like so much higher like our
chances are so much higher
getting it than like other people i mean
if you're not like working as much like
we're working
i mean i'm on a set it's like 200 people
every day
we have restrictions on sets of like um
yeah how many people can be in like a
room but everywhere is different i think
every city
every state every country has different
protocols because their number
everybody's numbers are different you
know yeah
um but that yeah on ours i remember i
had a shoot and there was only a certain
there was only like i forget how many
like 10 people or something
and it is very very restricted but when
you were shooting in that place amanda
like up in the mountains there was
pretty much no covet there so our sets
were like a little bit like you know
like the team was a little bit bigger
and we were more free
but towards the last week they had to do
a night curfew because they're like oh
my god it's getting really bad right now
like hope it was just running even in
that area so
yeah i feel like that's the process it's
like a roller coaster it's like
things get better and then things let up
and then
things get bad and then things tighten
up and it's just like yeah
and i think we're just waiting for that
2021 where
hopefully it'll be the year of the
vaccine and
yeah and everyone will be free of this
but
i think you've been really responsible
throughout the process of
it of getting tested of notifying
everybody
and not like state hermiting in your own
like self
quarantine and everything too what has
that been like just being
home like you you have your cats and
your dogs
right well today is day 10
of since i got the positive result and
um i'm not gonna lie i'm super excited
to talk to you guys
more excited even than i normally would
be because
this is definitely the most exciting
thing i have done
in a long time
yeah i've just been watching a lot of
shows and
um you know kind of just hanging out i
do
my i have a lot of animals and since i
was fostering the
pugs i um have a lot to do at least like
it's nice to have a lot of animals
around
because it's keeping me busy oh yeah
oh they're loving it they're like yes
mom is home
get all the cuddles well to help you
feel
good today because that's our goal of
our whole podcast we're going to spit
out some
random facts for you so we can all learn
a little something new
study conducted through dating sites
suggest that
women posting their photo get double the
emails
those who don't the same study says that
men who posted their annual income to be
250 000 or more i get 156
more emails than those who don't state
their income
at all sounds
uh
[Music]
get double the emails and those who
don't well yeah i guess
man who posts our income wow
so did you guys
do you guys use any dating sites i have
a boyfriend so
i haven't really been on many but i know
both of you are
single and ready to mingle so yeah but
how do you do that how do you like
miranda i don't know about you but like
if i've been on a dating site here
first of all you don't think people
would believe that that's me
that's like actually me they'll be like
oh yeah right
you're not this isn't you know them
yeah trying to trick them i would get
yeah i think i actually get rejected
more than like accepted and i'm like no
actually it's me
it's me trying to find a date like i
don't know how to do that though but i
actually i've heard that there are
celebrity dating sites by the way i
don't know if you guys know this
oh yeah yeah one of those
kind of i guess it's kind of like a
celebrity dating thing it's called raya
and it's like a dating app
are you on it yes
all the guys are downloading raya right
now they're just
i don't like i think i think it's so i
mean it makes so much sense
so many people must be on all those
different sites and there's different
sites for different niches of what
people are into or looking for
so it's super helpful in times like
these when people cannot
like meet people there's not going to
bars really
you're not like going and to the skating
rink
i don't know what what do people do and
then meeting people
so it's like yeah i don't know what age
group you'll meet there
but i don't know so
but it doesn't have um like a
exclusive dating site well in india i
mean
there's tinder right oh yeah
yeah that's like yeah so it's like i
know that tinder is pretty big here
um and i think
bumble is it bubble as well bumble is
pretty big as well but i'm pretty sure
there's like so many more
dating apps as well because people are
actually getting pretty used to it now
i know quite a lot of people you know
who aren't like
i mean you know what actors or whatever
not from the film industry
and they're like on tinder all the time
over here and even when we're
traveling they hook up on their you know
their tinder
there and i sometimes get a little bit
jealous i'm like that's kind of cruel
you could just
randomly meet someone and then just like
you know
i don't know like or even if when you're
traveling imagine just meeting someone
who'll be like hey yeah i'm a
local and i'll take you around and even
meet like friends that way and stuff so
i kind of feel sometimes like i'm
missing out i don't know obviously
because
you're seeing someone yeah so i'm like i
yeah i've actually i've always been in
relationships i've never really used
like dating apps but um yeah
if i totally would if i wasn't though
like i it would be so much fun
you can just never been on the dating
app ever never i've never been in one
and i've never been on one but i i wish
i was
at some point in my life before i found
somebody i'm getting
so much trouble for this episode
but i think i don't know i just think
it's
when i remember being in high school and
i was like i wish there was there was
just so many cute boys in this town
in jupiter and i was in another town and
i was like i wish i could just see like
photos of all them
and just like decide like okay
that guy's cool because i would just see
them all on the beach and i would never
go up to them
so like a dating app would have been a
great solution even then
you invented dating apps even before it
was invented you invented it in your
head
yeah yeah you know it would be good yeah
did you
what was um do you have any weird
experiences
from dating apps that you're comfortable
sharing kind of awkward because
all the opening lines like 90 of the
opening lines are covered related now
oh like covered humor like really
there's not a whole lot to work with
it's not really the funniest
subject but everyone starts with that
like
people always are like trying to think
of the main things you can say but
it's always like how are you holding up
and the times of code
and then miranda logs off it's like the
simpsons meme
that just bounced up
before it was like and now it's awkward
too because i haven't really
obviously i haven't been on the dating
yet very much
like or obviously i've gone out with
anyone on the dating app since i got
covered but
it is sort of funny now because it's
like should i always think
should i tell people like these people
i've never met before should i be like
well actually i have it
here here's an icebreaker he's a nice
icebreaker i'm moving
positive you know if somebody told me
that like up front i'd be like this
person like is awesome
like they opened up with like an honest
like a fact about them that could steer
me away
but but it's not it's so funny because
it's like obviously like people
quarantine and it doesn't stay with you
forever at least
what we know you know it doesn't stay
with you forever so
it's not like um positive for life yeah
exactly
so it's like all right i'll wait like a
month
and then if you're good and tested we'll
hang out maybe if the mayor lets us
you know this is like a bad rom-com
already
like you meet someone and you like your
eyes
straight i think i feel like there's so
many films
so many films are gonna happen like
covet based films
like by next year like you said like the
rom-coms the horrors
i only want to watch i will only watch
stories based off of miranda's life
[Music]
that's gonna be fun for you it's not to
be exciting
that's all i want every story i get i
love it so much
i think it's so it's so
just honest and comedic and like
just awesome and temporary that's why it
can be comedic
um but moving on so did you know on
february 1st
2009 comcast accidentally aired 30
seconds
37 seconds of porn
during super bowl cardinals and the
steelers
dealer nation clashed during the intense
final minutes of the super bowl game
with just
three minutes remaining the cardinals
had just taken the lead
and after facing almost certain defeat
the broadcast made a switch
to an initially innocent enough scene
which many no doubt mistook as a
commercial
what came next however was certainly
unexpected as the scene played out a
woman was visibly
grabbing the man in the genital area
while trying to unzip his pants
and then within mere seconds the man
stood up to remove his pants revealing
full male nudity on live television
watch out janet 37 seconds of club
jenna aired until comcast was able to
stop the production and get back to
business of football
wow
i don't know that's all we got that's
all the information we have
this is 2009. yeah so
good um they're so lucky there was no
social media then
like there wasn't much of it that's even
hilarious
so trolled like and it would have just
it just wouldn't have stopped the only i
mean the only bad part is like children
watch the super bowl too yeah
just like a lot of questions
after that uh that's super hard
yeah i like the description just full
mail
nudity
sounds like the dating apps all right
today's episode is brought to you by
clorox when accounts trust clorox
the same way we trust essential workers
to provide the care they give to us our
families trust
us to give them a safe and protected
home our community heroes trust clorox
to keep places like hospitals and
grocery stores disinfected
so i know i too can trust clorox to
provide my home with a safe environment
at home
we can all enjoy that's why i trust
clorox regular bleach by mixing one
third cup of clorox regular bleach with
one gallon of water and used as directed
on hard
non-porous surfaces it kills 99.9
of germs and bacteria on a variety of
surfaces from our kitchen floors
to the counters to the bathroom tubs and
to of course
the laundry whites i know i can count on
clorox disinfecting products to give
myself and
my family the best home we deserve
clorox disinfecting products are so
important in my home especially with my
little puppy running around making a
mess of it so i make sure to use them on
my floors on my counters on my door
handles
and yeah it's just keeping my home nice
and
clean because when it counts trust
clorox feel
good all right eating bananas can help
fight depression i need this actually
bananas help
overcome depression due to high levels
of tryptophan which is converted into
serotonin the happy mood brain
neurotransmitter
i just i just heard actually because i
was on a set once and there was like a
guy an 80 on our set who was eating like
three bananas like every time i see a
day like every time i see him he's like
eating a banana eating banana
i was like why are you eating so many
bananas like that can't be good for you
i was like no actually it's sugar he's
like i have anxiety
and apparently bananas also have like
zinc or something
but like so he's like yeah it's from my
anxiety i've been asked to have like at
least
up to three bananas a day but like
bananas are my favorite fruit so i love
bananas i could have them all the time
i love holistic medicine that's awesome
yeah i have a banana right here to eat
it
you want to are you into this that'll be
the thumbnail
okay
[Laughter]
that's why they're sweet when they're
brown and isn't that when you're
supposed to make stuff out of them
because they're sweet yes
you need to make banana bread now that
would be fun i might spend the rest of
my day doing that after this i'm not
even kidding
i can't wait oh my god i love banana
bread but are you
miranda are you on a special diet but
for like for covid
um no the doctor told me that if i ended
up having any breathing problems or if
it got worse that i should call him and
he did say that there were
different options of things medication
and things they can do but
i got lucky and i didn't have to ever do
that so
i'm just eating kind of whatever it's
not
i'm probably not doing the best job i
should be eating
healthier i've been eating a lot of um
drinking a lot of peach snapple and
eating a lot of cake
oh wow this is definitely not a coved
helpful diet
comforting whatever quarantine i guess
where are your parents right now
actually live with my parents normally
but i had to leave
because i couldn't they both tested
after i found out that i tested positive
and they both tested negative which was
also really great
um so they're both doing really well and
they still have don't have any symptoms
so i think they're going to be
fine they didn't get it because i think
10 days is enough
i think that's about the amount of time
um
to know for sure but but yeah so i had
to
move out it's kind of funny because
i should have already moved out a really
long time ago but this sort of thing
like i should have looked down like 18
i'm 27.
so i have my own place so i just went
and actually
now i'm actually staying here
do they miss you um i think so i mean
they're calling me a lot and checking in
on me and stuff
but i feel like a little bit of them
might be enjoying it
maybe a tiny bit just because now they
have like the house to themselves and
plus i have so many pets and my pets
were with me at their house
so that's probably kind of nice for them
to not have to worry about all that
but you have two dogs i have two pugs
that i'm fostering and then i have
a dog and then i have three cats so it's
a lot stirring
yeah yeah she's keeping them but if
feel free to reach out to her i don't
think she's going to give them up
but i don't want to still have an
application
give it your best shot the way when you
guys say foster because we don't
i don't know like we don't really have
like that not that term here but like
what what do you guys mean like when you
say you're fostering a pet is that like
you're taking care of it
in the meantime so the owners get back
or um it's more like from a shelter or
from a rescue you could um keep them
for a while like a lot of people will
foster puppies until they're
like maybe if their mom isn't around for
some reason and they'll bottle feed them
and then when they're ready to get home
they get homes but
i just found these two pugs randomly
walking down the street it sounds like a
lie like i stole someone's bugs
but i really just found them that's what
i think
they're so cute though oh my gosh
like yeah the names are great too
and you pick the names you call them
harold
and mod and mod
but doesn't it become really difficult
it's like you're you're fostering them
but
like you've given them names or is that
is that fine because then when they move
to the next family they'll have names
um well i've only ever fostered one
other dog that i
um found and they kept his name so
i don't know sometimes the people
actually stick with the name but
um but yeah there's a good chance they
might change them too i hope harold and
mob stay the same
please do it they will because i don't
think they're like we'll never give them
up
[Laughter]
but still put in the applications guys
miranda cost please
ig finder and how do people
how do how do you work with an adoption
agency for okay which one
an adoption agency so it's an open
adoption i'm looking for
in a way i want to have to visit them i
have to be a part of the people's lives
as well they have to adopt me too she's
not joking
she's not joking you're like this is not
a joke at all
this is very serious i know i'm kind of
like confused here i'm like uh
what's going on right no being adopted
yeah but she said she found strays
strays and then
um she brought him in her house and
she's like all right
i will take care of these two puppies
until somebody decides they want to take
them home
and i'll give them a nice home in the
meantime so they don't have to be
in some sort of place and kennels and
all that stuff
yeah and or the streets so she or get
killed in like
a shelter i don't know so she holds on
to them
until somebody um suitable
reaches out to adopt these puppies but
and i say puppies but i don't think
they're puppies
but yeah oh my god
but they're they're the cutest bugs
that's
so nice of you though seriously like if
you come to india
you're gonna have such a hard time
because there's strays
everywhere right and like oh my god
amanda you know like they're all it's
crazy there's
it's just it's not just dogs it's like a
lot of stuff there's like
monkeys monkeys so if i move to india
i'm gonna have to open a farm
yeah you will you won't leave india
yeah you won't leave like the rest of my
life
yeah like miranda i see you two together
in india
i'm like wait
so cute though i mean but even with
covet though
going back to that it's just such an
interesting topic because this is what
everybody
is scared of happening you know like and
but you're living it you're experiencing
it i had another friend
um the mayor of miami that had kovid too
and he felt fine like he had a similar
situation but i
also had another friend that had it and
he was a bit older
and he was just suffering the whole time
he was like it was like
an uphill battle every single day of my
life and i'm
so happy i'm feeling better and i'm so i
didn't think i was gonna make it through
it
so it's just crazy the different
experiences people have with it
um and some people get really lucky with
like stronger immune systems and
everything or just in general but
it sounds like a phantom thing
if you've never had it but then once you
start hearing stories of about people
around you that have had it you're like
oh [ __ ]
like this is reality this is a real
thing this is happening
so i think it's so cool that you're
willing to share your story about it it
makes people realize that is
a real thing you know it's like miranda
can get it you can get it
so be safe
i know it's crazy hearing the different
levels of people having it too like i
know somebody
who is in such good shape and like 30
years old and
he was in the hospital for a few days
because he had fluid in his lungs and
then
i have another friend who is like 25 who
got it and
she's like me she didn't really have any
symptoms except the no smell or taste
but it's so weird she said it it lasted
for almost three months
um not having her taste or smell even
though she was testing negative for
coven
so i guess sometimes that lasts a while
for some reason
like different lengths of time it sounds
so terrible though
um miranda you're so lucky you're
asymptomatic like i mean well i mean
almost mm-hmm yeah yeah that's great
how does that work with um because you
film your show every week right
for michigan um actually no we um we
just film it a couple times a month
so we're probably they aren't going to
do it the next time around
and then i'm just going to keep testing
and i think you have to test
like you can't just test a negative ones
because they do come up with
um false negatives a lot so um
i'm gonna have to test multiple times
once i test negative
um in order to be able to go back but it
was weird because when i saw the
positive i thought well maybe it's wrong
i don't know my initial reaction was
it can't be right i don't have it yeah
so when i first saw it and i called the
doctor
he was like no he was like like false
positives are very
rare but false negatives were kind of
common i guess
he was like and he sort of explained it
in a way that i kind of understood he
was saying that it's because
whatever it is that they test for to
figure out that you have
covid obviously if it comes up negative
it's because
they did that wasn't there but if it is
there obviously it's there
so you're positive like i don't know i'm
not explaining it very well no i know
i'm not good with science
but it sort of made sense to me when he
was when he was telling me why
it's crazy times guys it's crazy time
going back to um
mission unstoppable because that's
mainly what you're focusing on right now
outside of covid and in doing that
that's hosting and you've been acting
your whole life was it a weird
is that your first really hosting
like ongoing job that you've had since
um yeah it is it's actually um i love
reading a teleprompter because you don't
have to memorize the new lines or
anything so that's homework
yeah and um and it's just a fun job
because i get to learn about a lot of
different people and
uh different jobs that i never knew
existed in stem
um like this season we uh
i didn't get to go but um they actually
went and like interviewed a lady who
um she tagged sharks so all day long
every day she just goes around in a boat
in the ocean
putting tags on shark fins and she had
to figure out how to do it in a really
fast
um really careful way obviously to not
get
eaten yeah um so it's just exciting and
fun like getting to
to hear about the different crazy things
people do like i never even knew that
was something
somebody did so right yeah you don't
really think about those things you just
like
know they have tags on them but yeah
how do they get there
um yeah and they're always just
interviewing different people and they
interviewed the lady that um runs the
mars rover
really yeah and um everybody just all
the different women they interview they
have really cool stories like
um they all had people telling them like
you're not gonna make it or there's no
way you're gonna be able to do this
like so many of them just believed in
themselves and didn't really have
anybody around them telling them
that it was going to happen in any way
like most of them had people
kind of against them so it's just
inspiring like hearing all their stories
it makes me feel like
you can do anything what what's one of
the like
i guess out of all of your all of your
experiences in in hollywood and
in business what's one of the most
important lessons you've learned
um well just from auditioning from a
really young age i feel like that
definitely um it's hard because
so many so much of acting is rejection
you know like going on auditions and
having people tell you no 99
at the time so um in a way it is kind of
sad but then it also i feel like
it makes you build up confidence in
yourself like you have to believe in
yourself when lots of people are telling
you no
so i feel like um i don't know that's
kind of a good lesson to learn
even though it can be hard when you're
little just because
um you never like it's good to not give
up obviously and to know
um just to really believe in yourself
and
and
not to listen to other people yeah so
when you were a kid like did that affect
you when you when you'd get rejected
auditions um i think when you do cry
um no i never really got too upset
because
i sort of felt like i was always doing
it like some little hobby on the side
like my friends when i was little um
most of my friends would like
uh have different sports they were in or
they'd dance or something so to me it
just kind of seemed like some
like extra activity i was doing um
so no i don't think i really cried or
got too upset but
um it's still hard when you're you know
eight or nine or ten
and you're going into rooms and like
trying to say the lines and do your best
job and it's just weird being in an
audition room even
like even now i don't i feel weird
sometimes in waiting rooms
for auditions just because you know
you're all going in on the same part
and you all want the part and it's just
kind of an awkward experience
mm-hmm well that's why i love smelly
tapes
yeah but you guys talk to each other at
auditions
um yeah i do talk to people sometimes
people seem like they don't like it when
you talk to them like they want to focus
on the script i don't know if
you guys have ever been on an audition
marina is trying to make
friends in the waiting room i'm like hey
you're so cute you're like i was on
drake and drake and josh
i remember when i was like when i was 11
years old and i
really wanted to start modeling and my
sister was 14
so she was like she started modeling at
that time
and um i was 11 and because my sister
started modeling i was like
i have to be in this fashion show and it
was like her first fashion show
and i was like i have to be in this
fashion show i have to be in a fashion
show and they're like you cannot be in
the fashion show you're 11.
i was so upset that day i was just like
i was crying and even when my sister
left for the fashion show
i couldn't get over it i was like i
can't believe i'm not in this fashion
show
i was really really sad about that and
they eventually like
yeah you jacqueline just wants to be
as a child i've learned she just wanted
to be included
and like nobody would include her either
so
like you were the youngest sibling or a
child in your family
yes so i had to be a part of everything
and when i wasn't i was really as i
would throw a fish
and then like i did a little bit like
then my modeling started like i think 15
16 onwards
so but it was a struggle guys it was a
struggle like
you made it though 11 i was struggling
miranda you go to india
all you see is jacqueline's face
all over billboard's everywhere yeah
i go there and i'm like holy oh there
she is again
there she is again and i'm like oh my
god
it's so awkward if you beat somebody
they'll have to see you everywhere
all the time that's like the ultimate
revenge yeah
it really is they can't
get away i think that's like that's the
thing like even if you date someone
famous
like do she it's just jacqueline looking
looking yeah somebody's really pretty
they're like really nice pictures too
it's not like
when a bad picture comes up on like
instagram
that your friends that would sound like
that would suck if like i had a
billboard and it was like the worst
picture
you know what happened to me before um
with one of my friends
like we were shooting photos together
and she's like oh okay make sure you
edit it and do this and do this
because i'm like okay i got you and then
i did it
i post the picture and then she posts
the same picture but
the unedited one and then yeah
so it looks like i edited her
you didn't think she looked good enough
yeah
i'm like you
i was like and you know what i'll okay
yes i did it
sure it was all me i wanted to take the
extra 30 minutes
of my time perfecting
the notes i was given like oh did she
explain
why she didn't i didn't i never even
asked
but i will i will bring it up though
i'll call her out
because there are any answers i do need
answers
i i don't know if was sabotage which has
happened before
why don't you have your 6 26 on you
right now because it's morning time
jacqueline for me today and i'm
trying not to be always
drunk no i um
actually you know i would drink wine in
the morning honestly i i think i like
wine
more 66 66wine.com um
miranda have you tried her wine yet i
have and you know what's funny i
had only ever tried wine maybe one or
two other times in my life and the most
wine i've ever had
was amanda's wine it's literally the
most i had an entire glass
whoa very good because that's how you
know it's good
wow an entire glass you would not go
beyond an entire glass
the most i've ever had maybe i will next
time i'll keep taking it to new heights
quarantine's about to get real fun for
miranda so
but we do have some final questions from
fans that we want to ask you before we
sign
off today so you can rest up some more
and yeah baking some more bananas yeah
so um our first question is
what was it like working on icarly you
must get this
and how old were you how old were you
when you were filming that
um i started filming that show when i
was 13 and
um i think it ended when i was i think i
turned 20 like a couple months after
it ended so all my high school years
were
on the show and um it was actually
really i had
mostly 99 a really fun time doing it
it sort of was like high school i think
in some ways even though i did
homeschooling to do the show just
because um we always had different guest
stars on and
like cute guys and stuff and like we
were always
like me and jeanette who was on the show
with me we were always
like sometimes we'd like the same guy or
sometimes like
i don't know i just feel like you went
through some of the high school stuff
um doing the show so um i definitely
have a lot of crazy memories
from that oh and it was fun getting to
travel for the show because i had never
really traveled
before at all so um just to get to go to
different countries and meet people and
we got to do like signings and things
like that so um
yeah it's definitely a cool experience
the next question is who is your closest
friend
and where did you meet um
one of my best friends and my oldest
friend was my next-door neighbor my
entire childhood
her name is nina hi nina um
and yeah we it's actually crazy her dog
just had its night to take everything
back to animals but her dog just had its
19th birthday
and when she moved in next door to me
when we were eight she got the dog
so um it's just crazy her dogs have
like all her animals live the longest of
anyone i know
she needs to start a blog about yeah i
always ask her what do you feed them i
want to copy everything she does
but um yeah she's pretty much she's my
best friend she's um
and she's like a realtor so she um
isn't in the entertainment business at
all and um
yeah she's the best i had a dog that
lived to 19 as well
really what kind of dog was it what
breed it was a palm
oh how cute yeah and like we got her we
got her when i was a year old
and then like like literally she was
there until i was like 20 so like i
i grew up with her you know and um she
was really fat like she ate everything
everything because we were four kids so
we would always like give her like our
food
like whenever we were eating she'd eat
our chocolates she she drank
like pepsi and coke like fizzy drinks
like everything
like she was addicted to that stuff and
then she would and then like even if we
were chewing gum
she would want our gum so then we'd like
okay and we'd give her our chewing gum
and she would eat the chewing gum she's
like gobble it up
and then she lived in 19 and she looked
at 19 she got really obese and then we
had to put on a diet
and then um and then but she still left
at 19 actually like
she she got really old i think she would
have lived for longer but we had to put
her down
because she was that old oh like she was
like
she couldn't see anymore and she
couldn't like she was like barking at
walls and like sitting in her poop
and then we're like you know what it's
just she's just too old right now
and like it was like you kind of felt
like
i know it was terrible it was terrible
it was like this
is a really impressive life that's all
yeah my friend's dog barks at walls too
and the vet thinks that she has
um dementia and i don't know that dogs
could even get that yeah yeah
terribly old for a dog like it's like
yeah
trucking along yeah that's crazy
jacqueline
you don't write a blog about how your
dog lived to 19.
i think you got lucky um
your friend should write a blog thank
you so much
miranda for being on today thank you
miranda it's so lovely to speak to you
yeah it was great to meet you and this
was the most fun part of my week
yay and thank you guys so much for
watching make sure you subscribe
so you catch our episodes every tuesday
you know where to find us and thank you
so much we love you and we'll see you
next week